well you darvish making his tenth start
in a padre uniform and also the 13th
against samaras this is his first start
against the mariners since 2017 when he
was with the texas rangers he has been
no short of excellent this is right
under the teeth of the shift kronerworth
actually backed up but still there's
plenty of time to get walton for the
first out
popped up
around second base and jake cronenworth
now tatis now crawl to work
2-1 to seeger is popped up into left
center field the wind's going to knock
it down
and fam coming on to make the catch it's
a one two three first for you darvish a
padres are
this afternoon overall seven starts on
the air a one and two record three six
three era
the veteran profile
did he go
check out a third he did
crew chief ted barrett
[Applause]
just two down
[Applause]
to right field coming on as myers not
going to get it
cronenworth gets it back in quickly
first base hit for the mariners
runner goes throw down the second wide
stolen base
kyle lewis two for two on the season
bottom of the second inning fernando
tatis jr leading off against justin dunn
high drive deep left field
hit number 200 for tatis is home run
number 51
and the padres take a one-nothing lead
he's showing no mercy right now
he is that
locked in
at the plate
12th of the year for fernando tatis jr
441 feet to left center field
2-2 to mayfield
and a swing and a miss garbage picks up
strikeout number two
swinging miss and he strikes out don
back-to-back case
for darvish two down here in the third
inning
one and two to fam two outs third inning
good pitch great inning justin done he's
got root raisin to be fired up
second strikeout of the day
swinging a mess as elevating was garbage
and he strikes out lewis to pick up his
fourth k two down well don that's the
clinic right there pitching backwards
[Applause]
coming on hard as profar can't get it
base hit
hagerty
he's at second with the lead off double
[Applause]
one out hagerty at second and jack
mayfield coming up
on the ground to first base osmo with a
good pick on the backhand he'll win the
race to the back crowd number two
well that ball changed direction and
hosmer comes up with a big stab at first
hagerty on to third
with two down and justin done the
pitcher
put it in play
drives will myers back over his head
bears have tied it justin done
with a rbi double ties the game at 1-1
with two outs here in the fifth
two-hole pitch let it fly how about that
strike three call
fifth strikeout for you darvish came at
a pretty good time merits have tied the
score one to one
[Music]
pitch
swinging to miss got him
third strikeout for dunn
2-2 pitch and a big one
swinging a miss struck him out
dunn pitched himself into and out of
trouble to keep it
a one-one ball game
[Music]
lined and caught by hosmer at first
sinking line drive a step and a dive for
hosmer for route number one
[Applause]
first and third padres with fernando
tatis jr up they off pitch
and tatis rips it into left field for a
base hit
profile will score and the padres are on
top two to one fernando tatis junior
drives in the go ahead run
oh yeah well they're filled with friars
as will myers steps to the plate here
myers lifts the fly ball to left center
field
over is lewis to make the catch tagging
at third is chronoworth here comes the
throw it'll be cut off front scores and
taking third of the plays tatis and the
padres take a 3-1 lead sac fly for will
myers
caratini chops one to shortstop walton
will go to first base they get the out
there and a good pick but in the back
door comes fernando tatis jr with run
number four for the padres
on top four to one
bases filled with padres again for
fernando tatis jr
fly ball center field lewis going back
looking up this is still slam diego and
this is fernando tati's
a grand slam puts the padres on top
eight to one
if i had to guess it'll end up being one
of the longest home runs of his career
it's also one of the loudest petco
erupts the lead 8-1 here in the seventh
enjoy that stutter step around third
young man
on the ground on the third baseline
fairball up over the bag
hagerty over to play it kim the second
as carratini is going to try and score
from first he will it's a triple
and the padres take a 9-1 lead
right down the line over the bag and
into the left field corner
do you want nobody out for the mariners
in the ninth jay gudoy
hey there we go good noise first big
league hit digger the third being waved
in trying to score the throw will go
into second and seeger will score jose
godoy
with his first hit in the major leagues
picks up his first major league run
batted in this afternoon here in san
diego it's now the padres nine and the
mariners two
that's strike three the padres win
and they sweep the home stand
nine straight games all at home
and they won them all